steve
how you doing good to see you nice to
see you um
uh virtually um yes i have a bunch of
questions let's jump right on in i want
to start with uh right at the beginning
enola homes is fantastic it's going to
be a huge hit for netflix
um and that's all i have and no no i'm
kidding
no i got i got a bunch of questions for
you um the first is
is the gaming rig still working
absolutely it is in fact it's working so
well
that i'm i'm slightly loathed to
start throwing in all the new upgrades
that have just come out so uh
i'm waiting for the new cpus to come out
from a company which i won't name just
yet
and also the uh the new gpus which have
just come out which
everyone's talking about anyway so i'm
pretty sure you know which ones those
are i'm gonna upgrade soon if i can get
my hands on one
not easy to find i was gonna say um you
should uh call nvidia and say i need one
of the new ones and i'll do an ad on
instagram for you
yeah i mean yeah yeah i could do that i
could do that
uh um are there any other nerdy hobbies
that you have not shared on instagram
yet
um i mean i've shared my my warhammer
hobby i've shared my computer building
hobby
i does it get any nerdier i mean i read
fantasy books i'm not too sure how how
much deeper down that rabbit hole i can
go
before there's no return i i understand
um
so i think this is the most important
question i'll ask today um
how uncomfortable was it packing all the
muscles into a period-specific
three-piece suit
i think it was pretty uncomfortable for
consolata the costume designer it was
like how am i gonna make these clothes
fit
like come on this guy this is this is
this is not the right build for a
victorian man
um uh it was you know what
it's no different from trying to squeeze
it into an extremely tight blue suit
so yeah in fact they fit a lot more
easily
i would not expect that um
you you've obviously you've played
superman you've played the witcher
and now you've played sherlock holmes
these are all iconic characters
that have huge fan bases which one did
you sort of feel the most
pressure on in terms of inhabiting that
role
it's funny uh i i i try not to
focus on the pressure aspect of it um i
i make it more of a
personal mission myself rather than a
pressure aspect whether it be superman
whether it be the witcher whether it be
sherlock holmes i'm not feeling the
external pressure
it's more about me certainly when it
comes to
superman and the witcher those are
characters i grew up with
and and i love and i really really want
to represent in the most source accurate
way
possible and that for me was a was a
massive thing
and and still is a massive thing and uh
when it comes to when it comes to
sherlock holmes i wasn't reading the
books of sherlock holmes necessarily
and so i managed to absolve myself
of of this this duty which i put on
myself which is being a law
loyalist and it's always about the
details and it's always i'm the most
annoying guy on set
because i'm saying um excuse me you do
realize that
this should be happening and they
wouldn't do that and you haven't read
this then that means this would be
impossible and
everyone's just going henry just shut up
and do the thing and i'm like i don't
want to do the thing because
because he wouldn't he wouldn't do it
this way and he he can do this
but with sherlock because i absolve
myself of being that psychopathic law
loyalist
i instead had the wonderful opportunity
to work with jack thorne's script
work with harry bradber the director and
work with millie bobby brown
my my my the lead actress and also my
producer
it was we could craft a sherlock which
which was supportive of
of a nola as a character and for me that
was that was a real joy and so
to answer your question there's no one
character more than the other which i
put pressure on
i just i take the character onto myself
and it's more about self-pressure than
external pressure
you obviously are friends with guy
richie uh did you call him up and say
hey any advice on sherlock
[Laughter]
no no i didn't because he would probably
say listen mush you do what you want to
do
and you carry on uh i understand listen
i'm a huge fan of the witcher and i
think that the first season was
fantastic
i know you're filming season two for
fans of the witcher what can you tease
about season two compared to season one
i can say absolutely nothing i can tell
you that i'm at arbor field studios now
where we're shooting season two
and i just happen to be in a different
stage which is why it sounds a bit like
i'm in a cathedral
surrounded by something very similar to
a polystyrene fortress of solitude
so that's about as much as i can tease
about witches season two
i will not pressure you i will just say
effin cannot wait
um i this is something i put on twitter
i was gonna talk to you and
there's a ton of people that wanted to
know um are you involved at all in the
snyder cut
are you shooting anything additional for
that
uh not shooting anything additional no
it's um
it's it's all stuff that has been
already done obviously i don't know how
things are going to be
how things are going to evolve and
change and adapt depending on
on now a different length of movie
obviously and whatever may happen in
post-production
um whatever lessons may be learned from
what is it four years since justice
league came out
something like that yeah something like
four years four years worth of fan
reaction
and so yeah but uh it's for me i i'm
i'm now just just watching the party uh
the black suit looked amazing cannot
wait to see the
new cut and always a pleasure to talk to
you
steve always a pleasure i look forward
to seeing you in person again hopefully
soon
hopefully have a great day man cheers
you too